I'd like to invite Dr Ajit sarkar he is
a physician scientist with a keen
interest in data analytics and precision
medicine he is passionate about finding
meaning out of biomedical data and
leveraging them for better clinical
outcomes and his current work generally
involves offering meaningful and
translational guidance to biological and
Healthcare organizations currently
working as a senior bioinformatics
scientist I am sure we will be able to
learn a lot about the field and the
opportunities that the field has to
offer and with that now I'd like to pass
on the stage to Dr Ajit sarkar to start
with today's expert talk so over to you
sir thanks thanks for the opportunity to
to speak at this webinar so I know it's
a very interesting webinar I will talk
mainly just to give a very basic
introduction of Health informatics so as
always
I come from a very sort of uh maybe a
different background so I have done very
basic clinical degree mbbs almost seven
years back my interest was always on
data and data analytics so after mbbs I
shipped it I slowly shifted towards
doing my PhD in bioinformatics and data
science
So currently I work as a senior
scientist and I handle multiomix data
which ranges from
transcriptomics proteomics metabolomics
and I also work with EMR data health
record data and the building predictive
models after those data and also to
provide Solutions customer Solutions as
per their need so this course is going
to cover more or less
[Music]
I will I will limit myself to the genre
of Health informatics so it's more more
of a healthcare data science
so I won't speak at length on
transcriptomics or other multi-ohmics
biotech related or mixed things
and today is the introduction so just
let me start it so I have just prepared
a few slides for to for to for today's
top I have briefly divided them into
three sections experiences my
experiences
data science in healthcare where it
stands today and some of the challenges
and opportunities which uh which are
still now and which will be coming more
in the coming nearby future
so uh so starting with uh this has been
my journey so if you see it's more of a
transition from Healthcare delivery to
healthcare research so as I have told I
have done my graduation from uh in mbbs
and then afterwards I did my clinical
residency it's more of a physician kind
of role where I used to treat patients
and attend to patients like that
and then I slowly shifted to clinical
research
the research question was was majorly a
clinical
practice driven and I had my major focus
on type 2 diabetes almost six years back
now from Clinical Research I slowly
shifted towards bioinformatics and then
Health informatics so why am I giving
this particular particular slide and so
the the idea is to tell uh any learner
from any age in any stage of his or her
career or education that you can you
always have the option to switch and
shift from domain to other domain and
given and today given the amount of
resources you can access to open source
display sources
resources like Pine biotech so it's very
easy and given you have the motivation
and the right choice of your goal you
can also do such short opener switches
so again my graduation my clinical
residency and clinical research this was
main majorly for Academia so I had spent
almost six years you can tell in
Academia
research I I spent the coming five years
there would be overlap between Academia
and research and only for the last two
years I have been into the industry now
again why do I mention this also because
now nowadays things are coming surfacing
out that there is a big gap in Academia
and research and Industry and maybe
there are certain skill sets which
Academia doesn't Empower with us which
we need for the industry but still there
is plenty much opportunity to upskill
yourself to learn new things and this
might not be a very abrupt Journey for
some might be very abrupt for some and
there's always hope to trans transform
you yourself from Academia to research
to Industry so there are options so I
would just tell everybody to explore
more and more and things are not that
much of difficult and critical as it
might look you just need to be
consistent and things will surely work
out
so again the next thing is what did I
learned from Academia so is it nothing
that Academia didn't uh teach me or
there are something so yes there are
some things so in Academia is actually
the place where you where you go to know
the basics of biology so in my case
biology so the basic thing so what is a
cell what is the tissue what is the
organism what is a gene what is a
protein what is transcription
translation
what is transcription regulation so this
very basic basic things this nobody is
going to teach you nobody is going to
spend the effort to teach you these
basic building blocks is what Academia
can only teach you so from my
perspective IU so I got into the basis
of biology
music of medicine then health and
disease what is a disease how how do we
Define disease
and for for my special for my particular
specific background clinical approach to
medicine and public health approach to
medicine so this is more of a
professional degree so while I just
learned what to do and what not to do I
had a I had a very limited scope of
innovation or innovating or learning new
things or tilling or discovering new
things something which I could achieve
in my research during my PhD so so from
these academic background I strive to
[Music]
zoom in one or two questions one or two
pertinent problems and I I was taught
the taught the art of quantifying things
in my research so now I learned so
majorly I focused on quantitative
methods so how do we quantify medicine
how do we quantify a problem how do we
quantify uh suppose RNA expression in
normal cell versus RNA expression in a
disease tissue so this art of
quantification that involves
pre-processing processing and downstream
analysis so this quantitative approach
to medicine is what a research taught me
now that was also something uh
incomplete until I came to Industry
where I could bridge the gap between
Academia and research and make it into a
product a product that will be serving
purpose of multiple people
so this journey from Academia to
research and Industry this has been
quite uh quite uh I would tell
a diverse Journey quite a exciting
journey and there are things which you
get to learn only in that duration of
your life in that duration of your
career and you should try to make the
most
from wherever and whenever you are
right now
so now coming to the next uh big section
is data science and Healthcare and
biotech so where we are right now
so this is the this is a very uh this is
a survey market analysis done by uh
um McKenzie and company and they had
tried to identify the amount of Ventures
Capital which has been invested in AI
companies who work in healthcare
over the last maybe five to seven years
so and you see there are three uh three
large U.S Europe and Asia and this is
the uh number this is the Venture
Capital amount invested and you can see
the growth the growth is actually uh
tremendous so between uh these four
years that that has been a growth of
five weeks 22x for Euro and 28 x for
Asia so the growth would be is going to
be
massive in healthcare domain
Healthcare data again Healthcare data is
a big big source of data it requires
tremendous amount of data storage and
data Computing facility and with the
modern day computers all the GPU chips
and all those things cloud computing uh
the the healthcare data handling
capacity has increased but what we what
we are lacking is a proper human
resource who who will be well equipped
to handle this Healthcare data and
that's something which is uh which is
still uh pending and that will come in
the coming maybe one decade
and this would be the major things of
healthcare AI Solutions we can do
chronic Care Management so in any
chronic care it's diabetes hypertension
heart disease or atherosclerosis in any
chronic Care Management data and data
driven decision is what is going to be
the future of Health Care
self-care prevention Wellness so
self-care Edge as we entered in as the
demographic shift occurs so we will be
having much more geriatric population in
the coming one or two decades and so
geriatric population who will be
requiring more prevention more self-care
more home based health care so that's a
very important area for healthcare AI
prize and diagnosis again as so uh as
the as the disease burden increases we
have to stratify patients into high risk
moderate risk low risk and we have to
design the health care in such a fashion
at high risk patients get more attention
compared to low disk or moderate risk so
this triage and diagnosis is also
something very very hot right now
and all these things have shown us that
that diagnostic these rdpcr kits these
are a very uh such a domain of AI who
had Healthcare is going to succeed
clinical support So as doctor and
patient ratio becomes more and more
disparent as the patient burden
increases or a particular physician
clinical decision support tools will
surely come into place and Care delivery
is also something where point of Care
Home Based care these are very in very
primitive stage right now but that is
also where something uh where AI is
going to Mark put some marks so this is
the broad broad spaces where Healthcare
is going to transform
and if I just tell you from the company
name so this can be the I guess top 50
companies with the headquarters and
total amount of million raised so you
can you can see that almost uh it's
eight four nine zero million dollars
which is the top 50 funding reported and
the top 10 has around so around 58
percent of this entire funding which has
been raised so it's a it's a big
investment from the budget VC funding
and opportunities and solutions will be
massively increasing so we also need to
you know to prepare ourselves with the
right kind of knowledge and expertise
so now how data science can transform
Healthcare so just going to a bit of
more granularity right now so the first
thing is patient here so Healthcare
Healthcare uh the the central character
in healthcare is a patient
so data science would be successful if
it can transform health health care by
giving better and quality patient care
so what are what can be the key areas of
delivering good patient care so it can
be it can be there can be multiple of
things in this particular area
uh so managing appointments and clinical
message so there's something called uh
waiting time and this is a very
important marker of a
truly skilled Hospital facility uh where
the waiting time is minimal or the the
less the waiting time the better is the
facility and this is the better the
delivery service the bit at the footfall
so managing appointments and clinical
receipt precise Diagnostics so there is
something called proficient medicine
which is coming up in the last uh
five to six years and now people are
telling that no one disease is actually
one disease it's a cluster of multiple
diseases so arriving at precise
diagnostic using uh transcriptomics data
proteomic biomarkers
arriving at precise diagnostic will help
in the delivering precise treatment and
better recovery
early disease prevention prevention is
going to be the going to the next big
thing so right now we were focusing
mostly on key order so disease occurs we
have to cure it but even at a prevention
stage
things are now coming up that people are
talking about prevention that if you can
if you can have some biomarkers who is
biomarker Will will tell you that this
person is going to going to have a high
risk of type 2 diabetes in 10 years then
you will be following uh lifestyle
modification at a much earlier stage
so right now what happens somebody is
diagnosed with that up to diabetes and
the physician tells the person to modify
the lifestyle do some Diet restriction
and exercise but things are but info
reports and Studies have reported that
this may not be that much of helpful
because the pathology and the damage has
already been done so people are telling
that the damage occurs at least one
decade before the disease actually
manifests or shows up so prevention is
important so we can prevent it at a much
earlier stage and maybe these lifestyle
modification may be implemented one
decade back that will of course increase
the efficiency and reduce the mortality
Mobility there are certain metrics to
calculate uh
a good lifestyle and all those things so
prevention is a very important thing
which is coming up
so as I told that statification
classifying patients into high risk
glorious moderate risk and thereby
providing them cared is what is called
patients and imaging and Diagnostics so
as you know much of the Imaging right
now suppose a CT scan USG MRI they
already have some computationally uh
computationally calculating thing which
already diagnose so ECG already comes
with some automated Diagnostics
Automotive reports now Medical Imaging
is a big booming field and in the era of
kovit the thing was that to know that
this patient is suffering from kovit
rtbcr was taking suppose close to two to
three days
so for three days was a very quick very
critical time for a particular patient
in that case in that scenario people
were talking out talking about image
based and Diagnostics where based on an
extra image if you can identify whether
it's a covet case or a non-covet
pneumonia and that that that to do that
we need lots of deep learning
algorithms and deep learning algorithms
with lots of image data with a proper
compute facility so this is also
something which also is coming up
the next big thing is business business
and management so this has nothing to do
with the patient care but again has much
to do with the patient care also so what
are the uh big things if I can just tell
in one two three four five so first is
process automation
so suppose uh this uh this so Robotics
and these things will also fall into
this category
so Suppose there is one thing called uh
Diagnostic Lab trade around time so when
a sample is being collected from one
particular patient now that that sample
has to reach to the lab and the test
needs to be done now the smaller this
particular the mean the minimum this
particular time
the more correct the diagnostic result
and there are already automated things
so it is a sort of tubular
channels in the hospital so when you
collect the blood you just put it in a
you just put it you just open a hole in
the sort of a door in the window in the
uh in the in your wall and and using
suction technology it will automatically
take the particular while into the
Diagnostic lab which is which is located
in the tensor of the building so this is
a very uh very used example of process
Automation and we can we can use similar
automatic robotic Based Services for
healthcare or Administration claims
Administration so claims and medical
claims and medical insurance is a big
thing right now in the U.S in the Europe
it's already a big thing and the India
it's already coming up so claims records
are again massive Healthcare records so
extracting relevant information from
Planes claims history and then
calculating the premium amount
Healthcare premium premium amount and
all those things is a big thing and
claims and claims record Administration
is a big uh invites a lot of talent and
there are they are already trying to
automate the entire process to to
increase the claim settlement or claim
premium premium calculation time so
suppose you come with a claim uh history
of 100 pages so instead of going through
it
manually if there was a system which
could which could automatically scan it
extract all the important relevant terms
and then calculate a score of your risk
and then calculate a premium amount that
would be increasing the uh claim uh
claim adjudication and all those things
customer churn chat Bots as we are as we
are going to more and more mobile Based
Services so chatbots and business
insights these are also some important
uh questions in the in business personal
management
lastly we come to Pharmaceuticals so
Pharmaceuticals also includes vaccines
as well as drugs in my case and Drug
Discovery as you already know drug
Target Discovery uh drug Target
discovery that involves finding out
particular gene or genes which are
important in the disease State compared
to the normal State then finding out
drug molecules and drug and
Drug molecule and the drug Target are
properly aligned or docking is using
docking techniques so those things are
studied here planning Logistics and
improving clinical trials so clinical
trials is something it's a big it's a
big
sort of a revenue burner in the
pharmaceutical industry so much of the
revenue of much of the investment goes
into the designing clinical trials and
implementing clinical trials and this is
something also clinical trial data
ability to analystical trial data is
also something which is uh which needs a
bit of AI and data science right now
so now the challenges so for now as you
know the more the problems the diverse
the data yield the both the challenges
and the first challenge which is a very
big thing in data quality is and data
infrastructure so data quality is
something which is very critical in
health informatics so we have we lack
quality data aggregation as a integral
part of healthcare delivery so suppose
people capture Healthcare data as a part
of healthcare service so they are
rendering some service and in that
course they capture Healthcare data so
Healthcare data capture is more of a
secondary purpose and that what makes
the quality questionable and doubtful in
some cases
so that that's a big challenge because
models any AI model any ml model you
can't build a good AI or ml model with a
bad data so the assumption is we are
having a very good quality data and then
only you can build a proper AI or ml
model and the next thing is the lack of
fairness for healthcare data sets so
what is fairness well so fair principle
is something which applies to the
biological domain so data should be
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable so and data should be so some
so one hospital at maybe and in India is
capturing clinical data One hospital in
Singapore is capturing some clinical
data one in the London and one in the
New Jersey so now these four these four
uh hospitals would be having different
standards different uh different
structures of the clinical data but if
you wish to merge these four data sets
then you have to reach to a standard
procedure and this is a big challenge so
people will be capturing data in
different different pattern and pattern
and Fashions and you have to make those
data you have to curate the data and you
have to make it standardized and
harmonized and a lot of time goes into
this particular and data verification
for healthcare data
there are solutions so the first
solution is building more clinical
Registries so clinical Registries are
actually
pre-planned pre-planned data records so
it's not that you are providing
Healthcare and you are capturing data as
a secondary thing not not that you you
capture data that's your primary goal
and in the course of data capture you
also provide Healthcare but it's a very
costly thing to do Implement and
maintain and the next thing is preparing
a proper ontology for fair and data sets
so that what the hospital in Delhi those
patients suffering from type 2 diabetes
with diabetic retinopathy you you can
also get a similar set of patients with
a senior center diagnosis from other
locations also so given you your
property you are doing a standardization
of this disease column so you can map
multiple digits you can Club diseases
and you can do a large scale combined
analysis
the next challenge is actually
compliance and governance because you
know data Healthcare data is very uh is
very restricted and very sensitive
so and there are very complex regulatory
guidelines for healthcare data storage
collection and utilization like pipa
gdpr and cpgr
so there are lots of techniques which
people develop suggested
but it's not a very straight card
solution so the something is something
called predated line so in predated
learning so generally when we build a
model we take data from multiple sources
we we stored them in a central Depot and
we run the model there we built the
model there we run the model version
but but in case of Affiliated learning
we don't do that
the data resides into the local server
the model is built into the in the local
server and the model gets deployed and
implemented there also they are there
only but the model parameters
will be only the model parameters will
be stored into the central server so no
data is stored centrally all data
resides locally in the particular
Hospital in their servers only the
modern parameters are stored centrally
and and this is so there is a sort of a
feedback mechanism so as more data
increases the model parameters change
they update the central repo model
parameters which in turn also updates
the parameters of a different hospital
so this is how the theme works this is
called something what Federated learning
but again it's a very it's a very tricky
thing to implement there are lots of
expertise is needed for that thing but
there is a feeling in the industry that
things are going in that direction
because you can't
Aggregate and store diverse
Healthcare data into a central report
given the data sensitivity
lastly and which is where Pine biotics
and this program comes into place is
data science skills so suppose you have
data quality you have the time so you
have all this data collected and created
now what you do
so so there's a tremendous lack of
Health Data literacy among healthcare
workers so any any physician any nerds
anybody they have a tremendous lack of
Health Data literacy
and skilled and even skilled data
analysts who also understand the
complexity of healthcare domain that's
also lacking so those who come from
Healthcare domain have no clue about
data science and health informatics
so that's where this sort of course is
going to help and believe me again given
the huge uh huge
are going to be exploitation explode
in the
in the genre of data science and health
health informatics this is some skill
which is going to be required in the in
this particular Health Care industry and
this is where the knowledge and skill of
various data sources various Healthcare
data sources and data types and how to
clean them how to standardize them how
to curate them how to
conceive uh important models and how to
build those models how to test those
models and how to deploy those models
this entire skill is going to be a very
uh very rare skill in the coming future
so next I move to the challenges and
opportunities so challenges wise I have
already mentioned it in a iterative
fashion again I will just mention it so
one thing is that problem in data
acquisition
so you can't get data so easily and then
because and suppose for some cases where
you have to do some medical time
prediction suppose you have a person who
is wearing a Fitbit a variable from
where you are capturing the blood
pressure now now the blood pressure is
dropping down gradually and and it's
dropping down very steeply and it tells
you that the that the person is going to
going to have a fall because it's it's
going that it's going down consistently
now from there you need to give a
particular notification to that patient
or to to the relevant care providers
that this patient is going to have a
fall
so for that you need some real time data
streaming the data streaming and
real-time data prediction model
prediction and notification so this
entire thing this involves lots of
expertise you need database
administrations you need uh model
deployments you need data scientists
there are lots of things for a very
simple problem
but this is something which is a very
challenging thing
capturing and storing and predicting
from real time or near real-time data
which is very very important with
Healthcare uh Healthcare informatics
next as I already told data that
harmonizing data so you have to
standardize disease drugs symptom
procedures across different data sources
using proper ontology mapping so you
need to know that how do I standardize
disease how do I do this for drug from
where do I find the information that
which drug treats which disease which
drug should not be given in which
disease so what are all possible
relationships between drug and disease
so that is a very big area that has
something called medical
medical terminology and there are
multiple available ontologies and so
that's also which is very it's a very
important resource to be learned for
health informatics
next comes model building now model
building and I I guess we will be
talking more on model building so it has
two very vital steps one is feature
engineering one is model building so
feature engineering means you process
some biomedical data from different
sources it can be omic Source it can be
emr's vital variable parameters images
scans and images and you convert them to
clinical and meaningful features called
feature engineering so you just you just
translate or transform the data into
some structured features so this feature
engineering will depend on the data type
if you are using image data then you
will be extracting pixels and pixel
features if it's a colored image you
will extract
rgb3 different Channel features it's a
black and white image you will extract
only 0 to 1 to 255 black and white pixel
feature you if it's clinical notes you
will be building word embeddings
if it's a tablet data then it's already
a tabulated data you will need to
normalize it so this feature engineering
is something very important in clean in
healthcare data next comes so once you
feature once you derive the features you
can use them into the models but you can
you where you can make supervised models
and supervised models neural networks
graph Networks
another thing is after you build the
model for health informatics you also
need to provide something called
interpretability now Healthcare is a
such domain where you need to provide
the interpretation which is now being
called as interpretable AI so unless the
care provider knows that this is the
cause for which
so this is so this patient was having a
consistent drop in the blood pressure
for the last two minutes and that's why
the model has told me that he is going
to have a fall in the next five minutes
so this interpretation has to be there
in the context of healthcare informatics
or it won't be that much of Deployable
or translatable in the in the healthcare
domain so these two things are also big
challenges in the healthcare
informatics
now what are the industry roles now we
we all of we know about the
bioinformatician so who work with omics
data transcriptomics proteomics and yes
and this particular uh this particular
expertise is needed in this field also
majorly in in oncology where the idea is
to
subtype and precise subtyping of a
particular breast cancer or colorectal
cancer or any liver cancer and that will
help you to
scattered more precise therapy more
precise drug regime for particular
subtypes so omix data is also needed in
this particular industry that expertise
then something called clinical
information now this the role of this
clinical information is to work with all
possible clinical data it can be
clinical nodes where the person will be
using NLP based techniques it can be
image data where deep learning images
and all those things with transfer
learning would be used
medical terminologist I have already
told about this that because there are
lots of disparate disparate data sources
and people are using different different
terms so we need to do a proper mapping
and this is what is called medical
terminology is the job profile for that
so we harmonize and we map it so that we
can combine data from disparate sources
and and get a central
source for generating insights
biomedical data curation so publicly
available is lots of data so publicly
available data proprietary biomedical
data you have to queue it and you have
to structure it that's a big uh there's
a big demand of this particular job rule
in the in the industry biomedical data
scientist so feature engineering and
building AI models for clinical decision
support is something which falls under
the JD of this particular role on data
scientist and lastly something called
Solutions architect who actually connect
all the technical technical details of
uh of a problem for business problem in
healthcare domain so suppose we want to
a company wants to build a fall
detection algorithm
and the article will tell the company
that you need these these things in this
place you need to have a remote
monitoring device you need to connect it
to a database and the database will live
stream the data this will be the models
which will be running in uh in maybe
every minute minute or every two minutes
and there will be a notification on how
that had to be sent the entire
end-to-end thing is the what falls under
the domain of these Solutions architect
and there are many more Industrials in
the context of in the case of Health
informatics
so I guess I'll just end today's
discussion here and I guess I just took
uh four minutes extra and any questions
I'll just I'm open to the questions